le prochain budget ouais non mais
réformer le système oui ben nous on
demande de le réformer le système on
demande d'indexer les salaires sur
l'inflation on demande à ce que
l'ancienneté soit prise en compte on
demande à ce que les compétences soient
aussi prises en compte j'ai reçu une
fiche de paye d'une chercheuse bac + 8
bac + 8 c'est plus qu'ingénieur bac + 8
8 ans d'ancienneté 2700 € nets ça ne
paye pas les compétences et après on
s'étonne que nos jeunes cerveaux s'en
vont à l'étranger et aux ÉtatsUnis mais
ils sont pas rémunérés à la hauteur mais
il app aussi les entreprises à le faire
dans les négociations de branche il dit
qu'il exclut aucun moyen pour au final
parvenir à desardiser la France pour
vous c'est du vent mais c'est des
paroles des paroles des paroles c'est
d'Ida qui est qui est à matigon
excusez-moi mais je n'ai rien entendu de
concret qu'est-ce que les Français vont
retenir de son discours hier soir est-ce
qu'ils vont s'en sortir avec plus
d'argent dans le porte-monnaie est-ce
qu'ils vont avoir gagné plus rien il y a
eu des choses concrètes zé si allez les
a les a les aesh vont être pris en
charge par l'État pendant les les HE de
midi le périscolaire oh là là ça ça la
GA les pour les enfants handicapés
scolaris la gauche le demander ah il
nous a entendu ça va concern c'est bien
pour les avessages tant mieux et pour
les maires qui payaient parce que l'État
ne voulait pas
payer